ils sont une centaine ce midi massés
devant l'hôtel de ville de romorantin
dernier hommage à xavier juge les
familles élus mais aussi simples
citoyens quand j'ai appris que c'était
quelqu'un de romorantin j'ai été un peu
plus choqué que
les événements auparavant et j'habite à
côté de city mieux pour apporter vous ma
présence me soutient ses proches
voilà le discours qui précède la minute
de silence s'est volontairement court
les mots choisis simple ceux de la
deuxième adjointe
le maire est à paris pour l'hommage
national non pour la france mort pour
notre démocratie morts pour que nous
vivions libres
les habitants de la petite ville du
loiret chars cultive d'ordinaire la
discrétion et la pudeur face à ce drame
d'une brutalité rare les dernières
résistances tombe dans une colère mais
disons ça c'est vrai
et les mots me viennent pas je regrette
tout 7,7 lyle et tout ça je la comprends
pas oui la france tranquille trop
mauvais avant vous aviez juge les 37 ans
avait rejoint romorantin au début des
années 90 pour suivre son père militaire
à la base aérienne de pruniers en
sologne
les élus d'écrivains par an affecté mais
courageux et digne
écoutez elle m'a pas vraiment décrit son
fils je sais que je pense qu'il était
très fier delà de sa fonction et je sais
que son fils était avait vraiment
l'amour de la patrie et était vraiment
pour préserver notre démocratie
après l'hommage national à paris ce
matin la dépouille de xavier juge les a
rejoint romorantin une cérémonie se
tenait en fin d'après midi le jeune
policière a ensuite été inhumée au
cimetière de lantenay